good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight yesterday as you know an
American airstrike killed an Iranian
general called Qasem Soleimani for the
past 21 years soleimani commanded the
Kurds force which is responsible for
paramilitary operations outside the
national borders of Iran in that role
soleimani was believed to be a patron of
the Shia militias that regularly
attacked American troops during the Iraq
war he was also a major player in Syria
during their Civil War as well as in the
campaign against Isis though he was
little known to the American public
Soleimani was among the most famous
living figures in Iran and also among
the most powerful according to some
accounts second only to the supreme
leader of that country the Iranian
government has already vowed to extract
what it has called forceful revenge
against the US in response to his death
now whether that will happen and what
form it might take remains to be seen
but as no exaggeration to say that by
the next time this show airs we could be
engaged in a conflict a real conflict
with Iran from Ron's perspective were
already there if Iranian forces killed
the chairman of our Joint Chiefs of
Staff for example would you consider it
an act of war you would so what happened
yesterday wasn't just another symbolic
bombing sort T of the kind we've seen in
Syria it was a pivot point neo-cons in
Washington understood that immediately
congratulations to all involved in
eliminating Qasem Soleimani tweeted
disgraced former national security
adviser john bolton hope this is the
first step to regime change in Tehran
and quote that of course has been the
neocon objective all along the president
though has for years opposed that
objective and in a statement said that
regime change in war are not the point
at all we took action last night to stop
a war we did not take action to start a
war we do not seek regime change however
the Iranian regime's aggression in the
region including the use of proxy
fighters to destabilize its neighbors
must end in a must end now if Americans
anywhere are threatened we have all of
those targets already fully identified
and I am ready and prepared to take
whatever action is necessary according
to the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
meanwhile Soleimani was killed to
forestall planned attacks on Americans
but as he later conceded those attacks
would have occurred in the Middle East
not here in America president Trump's
decision to remove Qasem Soleimani from
the battlefield saved American lives
there's no doubt about that he was
actively plotting in the region to take
actions a big action as he described it
that would have put dozens if not
hundreds of American lives at risk and
last night was the time that we needed a
strike to make sure that this imminent
attack that he was working actively was
disrupted was there any imminent threat
to the US homeland these were threats
that were located in the region threats
in the region if you don't live in
Washington here's the translation that
would be in hostile Middle Eastern
countries places where American troops
would never be in the first place where
it not for the insistent demands of non
geniuses like max boot and John Bolton
but never mind no one in Washington is
in mood for big picture questions right
now questions the obvious ones like is
Iran really the greatest threat we face
and who's actually benefiting from this
and why are we continued to ignore the
decline of our own country in favor of
jumping into another quagmire from which
there is no obvious exit by the way if
we're still in Afghanistan 19 years sad
years later what makes us think there's
a quick way out of Iran and so on nobody
is thinking like that right now instead
chest beaters like senator Ben Sasse of
Nebraska are making the usual warlike
noises the ones they always make this is
very simple Ben Sasse wrote in a
statement last night general Soleimani
is dead because he was an evil bastard
who murdered Americans which is
essentially true Soleimani was certainly
a bad guy but does that make killing him
quote very simple it does not nothing
about life and certainly nothing about
killing is ever very simple in any
politician tells you otherwise is dumb
or is lying
yes Soleimani was linked to the deaths
of Americans nobody mourns his passing
but Mexico and China are also linked to
the deaths of Americans each has flooded
our country
with narcotics from which tens of
thousands of Americans die every single
year not that anyone in power cares so
does that mean we get to bomb Oaxaca
can we start assassinating generals in
the People's Liberation Army
maybe maybe Ben Sasse will call for that
too he's a former consultant a very
tough character but before we enter into
a single new war there's a criterion
that ought to be met our leader should
explain to us how that conflict will
make the United States richer and more
secure there are an awful lot of bad
people in this world we can't kill them
all it's not our job instead our
government exists to defend and promote
the interests of American citizens
period that's why we have a government
so has the killing of Soleimani done
that maybe no one in Washington has
explained how instead like Ben Sasse
they're telling us what an awful person
he was he clearly was so that's
irrelevant meanwhile it's pretty clear
that things could start to move in the
wrong direction pretty quickly we're
praying they don't but they could how do
we know that because we've seen it
before we fought quite a number of wars
around the Middle East in recent decades
we attacked Saddam Hussein twice as you
know in the end we killed him we invaded
an occupied Afghanistan we toppled
Muammar Qaddafi in Libya we fought Isis
in Syria in that for some reason stuck
around we're still there we joined
humanitarian missions in Lebanon and
Somalia our special forces have been
quietly fighting in Yemen Pakistan Niger
who-knows-where ellos many other places
in every single place each of these
conflicts has turned out to be longer
and bloodier and more expensive than we
were promised in the first place the
benefits often they've been non-existent
a lot of lectures about how the people
were killing deserve to die
certainly they did I hope that makes you
feel better one of the American people
think about all of this not that anyone
cares was too soon strictly speaking to
know the killing of soleimani happened
just last night but just five months ago
after months of supposed to Ron Ian
provocation Americans didn't seem to
view Iran as a major concern not even
close in a Gallup poll taken last August
just 18 percent of Americans said that
they backed a military force to shut
down Iran's nuclear program 78 percent
said they preferred diplomacy and
economic sanctions
so in a democracy you'd think this would
matter but as is so often the case the
preferences of actual Americans don't
enter the equation at all they're
immaterial in 2016 Donald Trump ran on a
promise of fewer foreign adventures
considering the ones we didn't barked
upon didn't work more very well he vowed
instead to focus on our problems here at
home which are growing against the odds
he won that election probably because of
that promise but ever since Washington
including some around the president have
been committed to ignoring the results
of that election and its implications
Washington has wanted war with Iran for
decades they've been working toward it
they may have finally gotten it